après une victoire pour sa première dans
le championnat de national le
football-club de versailles s'est
incliné vendredi dernier défaite 2 à 0
chez un autre promu le puy en velay pour
le compte de la 2e journée les buts du
puy en velay sont signées jacques bolle
en première période
et bal en fin de rencontre
[Musique]
le fc versailles réduit à dix en
deuxième mi temps après une faute du
milieu diarrassouba au classement les
yvelinois sont à la 7e place prochain
match vendredi prochain versailles
reçoit bourg peronnas dans le
championnat de nationale 2 fois ci
réussi sa rentrée un succès 3 buts 1
contre la réserve du stade rennais
konaté ouvre le score sur penalty à la
demi-heure de jeu touré s'offre un
doublé dans le temps additionnel samedi
prochain poissy se déplace à blois pour
la 2e journée pas de nouveaux titres
pour arthur rinderknecht le tennisman
saint germanois été battue dimanche en
finale du tournoi challenger de
vancouver défait en trois sets par son
compatriote constant lestienne 6-0 4-6
6-3 arthur in darkness sélectionnés de
nouveau en équipe de france de coupe
davis compétition à suivre à la mi
septembre et puis pendant tout le
week-end le centre aéronautique de ben
accueillait le championnat de france
junior de vol en planeur 39 pilotes se
sont affrontés
timothée gare et françois xavier poisson
sont les grands vainqueurs dans les
différentes catégories en lice